hey guys I'm Ryan all right and I'm
Katie Dubois
oh I came across the channel called
all-time tens and they have like the
coolest topics ever ten banned video
games is the video today I'm interested
in seeing what the band video games are
me too
hopefully there's like blood and gore
and like titties I don't know if they're
scary or like racially insensitive or am
I gonna be scared I hope so
really the game was set to contain a
song and they said no way what courage
children and gamble oh please that's not
the political racing game where the game
is to kill pedestrians oh wow there is a
game like that
I was like yeah grandma's football
manager 2005 okay
okay so like says oh yeah oh yeah wants
I'm gonna get dad for like how high what
it is Wolfenstein where's this band
probably turn
we've been a lot of no not surprising
one where the king
racial stereotyping and homophobia
Wow really
come on come on
really
really no way how crazy man all right a
lot of those were political a lot of
those are very political like yo you're
making our people look bad I'm gonna ban
this game right you know unfair Germans
should always be reminded of their Nazi
history that's true but they do have
some really important anti-nazi rules
over there and yeah that's actually well
you never play yeah you never play as a
Nazi killing people you're always
killing Nazis and Nazis deserve to you
know everyone who lives in Germany needs
to be reminded that they probably have
not see blue I don't know I think they
know they need definite reminders you
know like inglourious basterds thought
when they carved the Nazi symbol into
their foreheads that that is what we
should be able to do in these games and
manhunt to like that's a pretty popular
game and the fact that they banned it
reading that they had to tone it down in
the US and UK like oh my god what would
the original look like it looked fun
though when I was watching the footage I
kinda want to play you haven't played
that I haven't personally played manhunt
- I've seen footage before yeah I think
everyone
it looks variant time it looks so fun I
love doesn't you know like yeah in
someone's body I'm like rip out their
guns
oh yeah like they're spying or something
yeah like I wanted yeah mm-hmm I wish it
was like Kinect Rica's she's your hand
like beat someone to death and rip off
their genitals should hang out more we
should hang out more Phillie we have a
lot to talk about in plot I've heard a
postal yeah yeah yeah controversial game
containing urination racial stereotyping
in homophobia that sounds like a game I
could participate in really I don't like
I don't I mean I say I do enjoy a postal
that's not that doesn't sound fun to me
it sounds like a total blast I I mean I
guess there's an audience for that but I
actually think that's kind of
look I don't like hearing people pee in
general so urine no not cool the
real-life racism I don't get how you've
met enough people and ever to go
millions of people must be like you
because I met a handful of blacks like
you know I mean just know how does
racial stereotyping even possible I just
don't it never does n't quite make sense
to me being racist how can you know it
doesn't it's not like of all same thing
with homophobia it's like just get over
it yeah but to play a video game that
sounds like it'd be fun
but why include those things like why
not just have an awesome edgy violent
video game and not include those things
like you they purposely designed the
game to include those things like that
sounds they sound like [ __ ] to me
like that's not cool well I get why
you're here I'm getting I'm upsetting
your game I don't like that yeah what
I'm seeing a new side of you the side
where you stand up for morally good
things yeah well I always kind of shun
quietly but I don't I think this makes
me upset
one more thing um for a different video
the top ten form one you know grossed me
out the anal tearing ooh
mmm cuz you know like and there's like
ain't a tear on your body
yeah hey Carrie you have one yeah I
should see that video of your bodies if
you guys are new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out Katy do Blas Channel I'm gonna
be at VidCon this week stuff a little
late on uploads or lack of uploads that
is the reason why so spread the word if
you see comments of people asking why
and you can follow us on Facebook and
Twitter me on Instagram buying and
periscope yeah oh yeah I can I say one
thing you could say you shoot I'm
shooting next week so I've been in
pre-production yay cuz new videos soon
I'm shooting a film next week oh I'm
producing oh yeah so it's been I'm sure
it's gonna be a great film thank you
you're welcome